all right matthew yeah matthew
where'd you grow up where are you from
uh i'm from uh hayward california
is where i grew up for the first 12
years of my life and then
my parents moved to us to castro valley
california because we were in somewhat
of the
ghetto and wanted to go to a
a better neighborhood and so um
yeah i mean growing up in the the ghetto
i guess as the white boy
there were you know it wasn't anything
too bad i mean
i guess like once i got a knife pulled
on me and on a corner when i was like
nine years old
i think i saw i well i know i don't
think i saw a condom full of jizz
hanging from a tree when i was like 10
and that was like probably the
first time i saw anything like that but
you know it was just like there's gangs
and stuff
like a friend of my cousin got shot like
a couple blocks down uh and so around
that time a couple years later when we
moved to castro valley
and that was somewhat better but when i
got there it was more like
um i came from where i came from
and then i entered a more whitewashed
area and
then it was like instead of being the
white boy i was the
the white boy that didn't fit in because
i didn't have the money like or the new
items like everybody had or
clothes or you know electronics or
whatever and so
um i remember uh just uh
being a teenager and getting older i
liked playing basketball but i was never
good enough to be on the team
and um it's just kind of an outcast
trying to find myself and
and uh in high school as a teenager i
got
more into music and stuff and i got into
metal and punk and everything and uh
i i guess i one one year i remember
it was summer school i remember there
was a kid
named ben that he wore like converse
height
you know high top chuck taylors and he
listened to blink 182 and i like blink
22 which
i'm not by any means saying that they're
punk but you know when you're 15 years
old
that's uh so yeah i was listening to
stuff like that and um
i started getting more into that i
started wearing
chuck taylors and stuff and i remember
the next year ben's like oh you're a
poser and
you know all of a sudden it's like
you're finding yourself and trying to be
an individual and you're a poser
so yeah so um high school was
was cool and i mean it was there were
some you know
fights with you know kids that wanted to
pick fights and stuff it was
sounds like a pretty normal childhood it
was it was i mean i have some stories
except for except for the being an
outcast everywhere you went
yeah all right um no but i i definitely
have some stories um when i was about 11
years old
um there was a fall festival in castro
valley and since when we still lived in
hayward but
my parents wanted to go and it's kind of
like your wine and
arts and crafts festival so we go there
and i'm being you know
i want to go home i'm bored i'm bored
and my parents are having a good time
they're drinking they're drinking wine
they're having a good time and we're
watching you know some cover bands some
dad cover band and um
uh they are getting progressively
drunker
and you know not to the point where
they're sloppy
or crazy but they're just having a good
time and as a
child as a almost a teenager you know
i'm uh
getting embarrassed which who gives a
[ __ ] you know like who cares what
they're doing and what i'm doing like
but as an 11 year old being in that i i
have the sense that everybody's watching
us
and that all these people like i'm going
to see any of them for the rest of my
life you know
at this age i wouldn't give a [ __ ] like
i've gone to shows and danced my ass off
you know i've been on acid i've been on
mushrooms like at shows like
i don't care but anyway so
i knock the wine glass out of my dad's
hand i
slap it this little brat this stupid
little jerk
and that was it my dad
instantly went from partying happy which
they didn't drink a lot
they you know didn't have any problems
like that my dad
does have anger issues never beat me or
anything
you know i got spanked as a kid and he
definitely did a lot of yelling
um but you know we can go in more into
that later but um
in this situation it was instant change
the look on his face he was
i i knew i i [ __ ] up big time and my
mom
it was like a scared look on her face he
said that
he said get in the car let's go and we
got in the car
and he drove home probably and i'm
talking down residential streets this
dude was
i mean i have a very vivid memory and to
have this memory
as an 11 year old and remember looking
at the you know miles per hour it was 50
or 60 miles per hour down residentials
the whole way
and i was scared out of my uh
whatever i was scared and so we got home
he's just screaming at me you know like
i'm
i [ __ ] up and i did i totally
understand i mean
i don't know if i i mean i would hope
that if i had a child and i was drinking
i would have the capacity not to
you know do something like that but who
knows
um so he's yelling and screaming at that
point
my mom she's they're drunk and so she
passes out on the bed
well then my dad starts yelling at her
because she's passed out drunk in front
of her son
and that's not what you're supposed to
do and all this stuff and
i'm freaking out like i'm scared and so
i
run in the bathroom i remember he like
slammed the door open
and put like a hole in the wall and at
that point i
i was so scared that i ran out of the
house i ran to the neighbors and i
said call the cops my dad's drunk he's
freaking out
they called the cops and my parents had
to go to santa rita jail for the weekend
both of them because you know how cops
are sometimes they
it's not very rational it's and plus
when you have two really drunk people
they
don't really trust them or believe them
and so
yeah and uh i felt really bad and so
a little drama in your childhood a
little bit and i mean i
have always i've never been good enough
for my dad it's always
there's uh i i just i can't do it
there's things in life that like i
worked at a print shop and there was
like
he wanted me to install like lighting
and all these things and i'm like
well i've never used uh a electric drill
or whatever the hell it's called i've
never used one of these before and he's
like
mine's blown then i'm like i'm 35 now
that i was like this 33 year old man
that didn't have these skills which i
mean whatever
people learn their own skills and but
you know the stereotype
and he was mr manly man he was a
stripper in his 20s like big buff dude
and
that's whole that's a whole nother thing
but um
uh so yeah i didn't learn certain things
and because my dad would always say like
i'll do it like you i don't want you to
screw it up basically he wouldn't say
that
you know to my face but yeah so
there were different things like that um
i i would get in trouble at school but
nothing you know it was like stupid [ __ ]
like one time
like i pretended to stab the kid with a
pencil and that you know i like went
like that and that turned into oh he was
gonna stab me and i got suspended
or you know uh telling that i told the
teacher one time you're not my mom i
don't have to listen to you
[ __ ] like that like i wasn't you know
going and
bringing a gun to school or graffitiing
all over the walls or smoking pot in the
bathroom you know
so how far did you go to school uh i i
did a little bit of college i only did
one semester of college
um and you you've had jobs you have a
job now
yep yeah i've done i've done a lot
uh i did i was like okay in high school
like
3.0 or whatever grade point average in
college i
was trying to major in mass
communications because i knew people at
a local radio station that had referred
me to this school and to this teacher
i i guess i'm kind of one of those
people that i
have underperformed or had ruined my
potential
so you're working currently you have a
straight job
i do i do a gig through an app right now
i was working at a restaurant in
december and then they closed down
indoor dining which was fine because we
had outdoor dining
then they closed that down and then it
was like i was doing double the work
because of delivery
you know packing bags and all that [ __ ]
and then getting paid
like i mean not half but half in tips
because people don't tip
uh the restaurant for delivery they
tipped the driver
and so not that that's wrong i don't
really care i i didn't you know i wasn't
like oh damn it the economy is [ __ ]
i'm gonna take a stand or something like
okay time to move on to something else
and so i found this app um
through craigslist that does gigs and
you just pick a shift and you pick
time and how much you get paid and you
sign up and so i started working at this
warehouse
and uh it's it's pretty easy
um over time i've took on more
responsibility and
they've made me like shift lead and
stuff and
um it's it's it's all right it's not but
you can you consider yourself a good
employee oh
yeah man it's frustrating because like
most of these people 90 of these people
could give a [ __ ] but that's
what is the problem with these gig apps
i mean there's multiple problems but
that you're hiring people that don't
care at all
they have no they could give a [ __ ] if
they work hard or not
and these people that are managing it
they don't care either as long as the
job's getting done they don't care how
it gets done
so in terms of recognition
only i mean i have a few close people i
talk to and we
all know that we're great and i mean i
guess that sounds conceited but we
i mean it's just the fact uh and so we
talk and hang out and we
complement each other but there is only
one person that has come up to me and
said
out of their way you know like anything
and it wasn't a manager
um it was a guy that does boxes in the
back that i am
99 sure is doing blow in the bathroom
every day
this dude flushes the toilet every 10
seconds and then
is farting his ass off like i've done
coke
like i know the deal bro like you don't
need to flush the toilet like i
you can i can hear you snorting it and
i'm not gonna tell on you like
uh but yeah he he said that and that
made me feel really good and i was like
i was like wow that's amazing that
person like
thought to say that and he's actually a
really intelligent guy i've heard him
talking he's from the streets in oakland
and he's a
tough dude or so he seems he puts on the
front but uh yeah i like him he's cool
so so so you're you're a drug oh
yeah tell me about that you oh yeah you
use what so
i i use heroin i smoke heroin how long
has this been going on
uh so i started with oxycodone roxy's
blues 30s in
2012 a little bit i was dabbling with
that a little bit in tar black tire
heroin
i was working doing vending machines i
had that job for seven years you're
smoking it
always always i after doing coke for a
couple years i was sick of putting stuff
up my nose and i'm afraid of needles and
i see
i've seen what happens with that which
not saying that oh me smoking heroin is
so much better than injecting it but
it just seems uh you know but then again
i mean
i smoke cigarettes i smoke that i was
smoking a ton of weed which i
barely smoke anymore but i mean it
definitely affects my breathing
it affects my lungs and that's something
i'm worried about and that i
would like to quit eventually i mean i
actually was on methadone recently
but um my work schedule made it to where
i couldn't get to the clinic anymore
because for the first three months you
have to go to the clinic every day
that's part of the process
and i was doing fine it um methadone is
a little odd it's kind of
i don't know i mean obviously like if i
could choose
and if heroin was legal and didn't give
me breathing problems to smoke i would
choose heroin any day over methadone but
because methadone is socially accepted
in the world
and you're not smoking it and ruining
your lungs it's
obviously the better choice and it's
cheaper it's easier on the pocketbook
um and so uh sorry back to the
the roxies uh this is it was actually
2013. it was shortly after i quit the
music thing the vincent gallis show i
quit after that
i was done i was like i'm the guy
putting up all the money
all the time all the effort everybody's
saying great job man keep it up
but they're not the ones doing all that
so
i said [ __ ] it i'm not doing this [ __ ]
anymore and
shortly after that i had a best friend
named tiffany that would come pick me up
after work
we would drink we'd do coke we'd hang
out all the time
and one day she comes to pick me up and
hey blah blah blah i'm dating this guy
and he showed me these pills
and oxy cotton basically this is back
when the 80s the oc 80s were still
around
and uh for all the people out there that
know the ones you have to lick the
coating off and then
um excuse me uh
so she showed up and and i at that point
in my life was
i was 27 and i was just like sick of
everything
and was like might as well join the 27
club right
um which if you don't know jim morrison
janice joplin jimi hendrix all those
people
that died of like you know drug related
uh dust
anyway i didn't really want to die but i
was just giving up
and so i was like [ __ ] it i don't care
sure let's do it
and that was the biggest mistake of my
life
because i [ __ ] loved it and everybody
says don't do opiates don't do heroin
it's you're never going to come back
from it and of course i didn't listen
i have to try everything on my own uh
and
i mean you know my life isn't like
requiem for a dream now like i'm not
going to do an ass to ass for money you
know but um
i uh uh yeah i just i loved it and it in
it
people say some people say us other
people just get the nods and they're
kind of like
you know but it makes me like [ __ ]
boom i'm me i'm myself i'm happy i'm
free i'm energetic like
it's crazy it become it became what i
wanted it to be and it became what i
needed it to be
and that's crazy because it's like it's
like it took my
it's a [ __ ] crazy drug it's like it
took
my brain over and it just said like this
is what you needed and like this is
the way it should be and so there uh
like there have been multiple times that
i've tried to quit on my own there's
been periods of three months where i've
been able to quit
um when i moved to arkansas i was able
to quit for three months
especially i thought well [ __ ] i'm going
to arkansas i'm not going to know
anybody out there
so there's no way i'm going to you know
know about it
so um
your your drug use has continued you're
you're you're yeah you're still using
heroin today
right because yeah i couldn't make the
methadone treatments anymore and so
um i i didn't want to get sick and
experience the withdrawals
i've i tried to quit cold turkey back in
september a few months ago
but i got to day two or three day two
the first time and i broke down and said
[ __ ] add some straws with resin
you know shake those up with some
alcohol and put that on the foil
and you got you're good um but
does it affect your work no
no nobody has any idea nobody
i'm it it makes me better at work it
makes you like it makes you better makes
me better i've heard people tell me this
about
crack cocaine that these are adhd
people right like maybe i have that
people have said that too and i don't
know have you ever been diagnosed i've
had people tell me that
crack does the opposite what it does to
most people
it just makes them like fine or it makes
them slow
it slows them down calms them down calms
them down because they're usually they
can't
yeah focus huh yeah i think these drugs
affect everyone
differently right right yeah no yeah i
mean it
unless i start getting crazy and doing
too much
then it can it can kind of is it
happening
yeah because there was a time where i
was just like depressed and like didn't
care
and everything and so i was just like
[ __ ] it and spending all my money but
now i've learned that that's not worth
it because then i
get in too deep and that the money is
going to run out and so
i just pace myself and try not to do too
much and
you know uh it sucks when i'm home alone
sometimes and i'm just bored because
then i'll just like take hits
because i'm bored you would consider
yourself an addict yeah oh yeah every
day i do heroin every day all day every
day
you wake up and i wake up and smoke i
hop out of bed it's like
i feel like i'm going to some huge event
like the freaking
outside lands festival's happening today
and i get to meet all the bands just
because i get to smoke
like it's crazy like but you find it it
it prepares you for your day it makes
you make sure you're happy
it makes me i'm energetic because i get
out of bed and i'm like
oh damn i need to and you know what you
know what this sucks and this is making
me very worried besides the breathing
thing is
recently i've been waking up and my hand
is like numb
and like i also it might be carpal
tunnel because what i'm doing at work so
i'm trying to do exercises
but i mean [ __ ] i don't know if it has
to do with the drugs you know that's
that scares me so
and then i'm like [ __ ] i can't use a
lighter you know what i mean so
that really sucks but yeah
i have you have you met other people
that are
functional addicts like this uh
kind of but not like i mean the people
there were like people especially like
when i was doing oxy that was more of a
uh
so with oxy sometimes because oxy was
expensive let's get like 30
35 a pill sometimes and heroin is way
cheaper and that's why i started doing
it because it gets you higher and it's
cheaper
um and so oxy um
i would post this is back craigslist
made it to where you can't post certain
keywords now
but back in the day you used to be able
to post roxy blue jeans size
30 and then that's how you know i would
find dealer sometimes actually
um and i mean walking around the
tenderloin like walking pill hill i mean
i used to have to do it sometimes and it
sucked i mean
one time a guy tried to uppercut me it
was [ __ ] up just because i wouldn't
buy his pills his shitty [ __ ] fake
pills like
sorry dude luckily you missed i mean i
don't know what would have happened
but um not that i'm some tough guy i'm
not trying to sound like
i would've beat his ass no i'm not like
that but i mean i might have tried to
but um anyway i would meet people on
craigslist because i would i started to
realize and other people would do this i
picked it up
like if you sell the pills to somebody
else and mark them up or
a common thing i would say if i knew
they weren't going to
buy that many as i'd say all right just
throw me a pill or throw me a half like
that's when you're really desperate
you'd say throw me a half a pill and
then
they would and you know one time i did
that this girl we were smoking in a
bathroom
and she [ __ ] got on the floor and
started smoothing the foil out on the
floor of a dirty jack-in-the-box
bathroom and i was like
i'm on the wall doing it you know the
wall's smooth too and
i was like what are you doing and she
was little
you know and she's like what i'm just
i'm [ __ ]
you know smoothing it out i was like
dude on the wall the bathroom floor is
dirty and she's
she didn't care so yeah whatever
so i'd meet i'd meet functional addicts
uh somewhat somewhat
they were definitely eccentric they
definitely had their things and they
weren't reliable
oh it's not it sounds like you're you're
a case where maybe
your psychological makeup is but
nobody's gonna listen to that
you you will because you understand
because you've talked to so many people
and you pay attention and you care there
are people out there that have no
concept of this
and don't want to hear it does that sway
the world
i'm open-minded but yeah i mean i've
never smoked pot so i don't i don't know
anything about drugs the fact that i'm
doing this channel that
hey seems to revolve good for your drugs
it really does in my mind but but
certainly there's lots of drug stories
i don't even know how to spell marijuana
so so
so i'm just open-minded i find it
interesting that it helps you
yeah i believe yeah i find it
interesting you've never smoked
marijuana
i mean not that i'm saying like oh you
should or you should have but
yeah they mean the channel you know it's
no i'm not better than anybody else
no i'm never right neither i've got my
own problems i'm not saying i'm not
saying i'm better than any other addict
you know like
we all have our own things and we're all
we're all unique
we're i mean everybody it makes the
world the world and
sometimes it's the beauty of the world
that's the [ __ ] up things
i think finding something that helps you
find fulfillment and happiness is
important
and and if that happens to be heroin and
you're and you've got it under control
maybe maybe it's okay i don't know i do
but then it's the money thing
you know it's how much do you spend
that's a lot of money i mean what do you
spend a week or
a month probably fifteen hundred dollars
so i could have a nice apartment fifteen
hundred a month
fifteen hundred yeah because i i imagine
i probably do
500 a day nope 50 a day
it's illegal so technically you illegal
you could end up in jail
right yep yep uh so yeah
that sucks um but talking to you looking
at you you don't
look like the typical heroin addict and
that's why i'm still
probably here and functioning and not on
the streets you know
because if it started to affect me i
mean
i don't know if i started smoking crack
i probably would i know i can't count
how many heroin addicts i've talked to
that just nodded off in the middle of an
interview
right they probably also shoot up well i
guess people know i've known people
not off that smoke it never mind yeah
yeah yeah um
you know it's it's never happened except
one time
the worst story is i was drunk
and i went to my dealer's rv a guy that
was living in an rv
and i he he had terrible [ __ ]
it wasn't doing anything for me and i
was pissed and
because i'd have to travel like an hour
and a half to this guy um
and i was at that point this stupid very
stupid i said
you gotta have something and he goes
yeah i have fentanyl
and me knowing exactly what that is and
what could happen and everything
was drunk and said [ __ ] it i don't care
line me up some or whatever i don't know
how long later i wake up
and i'm like where the [ __ ] am i what
what happened you know and everybody is
around me
scared out of their mind and i [ __ ]
od'd man
i [ __ ] od'd for the first time ever
and that that really
that really upset me because i didn't
ever think i'd get to that point
but um uh yeah they had to
hit me with narcan like five times they
said and
like everybody they said i was turning
gray and like
like my like only only my girlfriend
knows about this
like nobody else knows about i mean this
is the people that were there but
whoo man i really tried to quit after
that man i got through like a week and i
was happy but
i was happy that i quit i was [ __ ]
bored out of my mind
you know but yeah that was fentanyl is
no good
don't do it everybody out there don't do
it yeah no fentanyl's a very different
game than heroin that's a [ __ ] crazy
game to play man
that's uh yeah it's a very common
move for a heroin attitude i do not want
to do that at all and i know
and i know there is some fentanyl in the
black tar heroine that's what i was
going to say is that you know very right
and they're lacing it and they're mixing
it luckily i have
you know even even crystal meth or crack
they'll do that with yeah
luckily i have i mean they can do
anything i think some of the girls that
work as
that have pimps will smoke a joint
and the joint might be laced with oh my
god you know crack or meth or
heroin or whatever and then they're
addicted and then they're they're
basically a slave to the pimp
yeah i knew i heard a story about a guy
once that smoked a joint with some
random dude he was
lost in the middle of the night and the
snow in chicago couldn't find his car
and some dude says
bro i've seen you walk by a few times
come in you know you could stay and he
seemed like a cool guy
he's like you want to smoke a joint the
guy's like oh yeah dude i smoke weed
let's smoke
[ __ ] smokes that it was laced with
meth dude starts jerking off in front of
them and [ __ ]
holds them captive overnight wow
i'm lucky i'm lucky the world you're
involved in by
using this this narcotic is
yeah probably better right totally and i
like i was saying i i have a reliable
dealer that i trust
um but that doesn't mean anything you
know he could get something that he
doesn't know about
you know but i mean at this point i'm
really just trying to make it through
until i get
the next job which should happen in a
couple weeks and
then i get a set schedule and i can get
back to the methadone clinic
because i know you know so you you say
your
your mind works better on heroin
could you ever get clean and and still
enjoy
life to its fullest i mean i did before
you know it's not like it's not like
before it's probably
before i started i wasn't enjoying life
i was just depressed in that moment
and i made a bad decision yeah you know
um
it sounds like getting clean would be
the best move oh totally yeah and i i
want to i
and i didn't even want to do methadone
because i said i don't want to replace
an addiction with an addiction
and my buddy's on methadone and he tried
to stop one day and he said it was way
worse than heroin
so i know there's maintenance plans
where they can wean you off slowly but
surely and i'm hoping that's what's
going to work
if not i i've said this to people i'm
close to and my girlfriend like
i think i just need to be locked up
somewhere you know like
for 30 days because i i am resourceful
i'm
it sucks i don't like lying and i i know
that probably sounds like [ __ ] i
really don't
but as an addict with the world the way
it is and
people you know would look at me a
certain way i have to lie
because i i need to get by and just
yeah i was living with my girlfriend's
mom and her for a couple weeks and her
mom had me pegged from
probably day two she told her he's on
drugs and i was with my girlfriend for
almost a year okay
uh she's smart she her ex-husband was an
addict
she knew she's uh she she and also was
making
you know longer trips to the bathroom
quite often you know
uh and i'd always like play youtube
videos i'll watch soft white underbelly
you know in the bathroom
everybody that watches they're like what
are you doing in there i'm i'm watching
the hillbilly
shut up there are a bunch of drug
addicts watching that channel yeah
so yep cool well your story is amazing
interesting i wish you the best of luck
and thank you man i like your
open-minded
attitude about yeah getting clear
opportunities about getting clean not
about using heroin
right no yeah i don't condone the heroin
use at all right no i'm not
i don't think so yeah awesome i'm glad
you're doing well
thank you yeah and i wish you the best
of luck man
thanks mark i appreciate it
you